[Music]
point up you go to the other make my way
downtown walking fast faces pass them
home down gonna turn and then gonna
shoot you down it and then in it I got
shot now have a bit how colton got me
whatever trail help help end it right
it's okay you didn't hear my done in the
none o your sister your sisters almost
here we almost got this yeah we're not
gonna betray each other we're friends
alright so when you come with me
alright Colton you've got the high
ground which means that you're going to
be able to shoot anybody friendly fire
or sister thank God
you're out here hello you can you have
the high ground you can shoot anybody
you want yeah yeah let's get you some
high points okay we should be able to
shoot them from here literally anybody
in the course from this vantage point
could we just got to do that okay
all right you want me to go low ah
that's it it's okay I think I'll survive
this money they're coming up no gets all
hot around Wow okay all right
[Music]
we got this but if you see anyone
shooting with that you're going to be
you so it cool down but you won't have a
thing you can wrap it by night if you
hold it down that's even better
you don't need to wrap it prep you just
need to hold down that's good all right
golden you stay up here you see them I'm
going to go track them
[Music]
[Applause]
the shooting gallery over here going up
I gotta move the background okay all
right I'm good for you call it
everything I got it out I've been hit so
hard
Oh God Queen Newt no got you ha ha I'm a
champion
next up everybody everybody enticed by
Brian Christine ominous shadow shock the
Prairie like a wild good I'll accept
this gazelle gonna eat it fresh apply
shouldn't talk so I announced my
christening but I still gotta find it
too much
now I'm gonna destroy them I'm gonna
make Colton drowsily come on you're just
mad
don't Estonia
and nobody gonna keep me down oh nice
dancing moves too bad they didn't do a
very good work shooting gallery I got oh
yeah
look at you move it move it that's close
one
almost made friends with the enemy I
don't want to do that I got to make my
way back to cold I think I'm done in
private I don't know what my score is
but I'm sure that it's in the wood Luke
will dig it
I've got to be doing all time I've
poured on them whoa are you moving
call them don't you time incoming don't
shoot it's me
it's become calm I did sno-cones been
betrayed if we take it out cold
how could you don't do it please I'm
innocent
come on ah all right
oh boy think old hash gift you're good
I'm a sweaty mess that's what I am right
Wow
all right you guys that phone in there
yeah good stuff good stuff yeah I think
that's where you what's up yeah how's it
going I knew that lady I can make it
missiles I'm sorry
yeah yeah the whole jacket was
incredible yeah but you guys be good if
you were at 300 halfway through the game
I don't even know what score you're at
make you yeah how'd you do yeah
congratulations
age playing holy crap I'm back hop am
indeed good